did you see that last night we've
actually got some voice questions from
at amiga as well
we do we have questions from adam for us
yeah dude i got it you do mm-hmm okay
sweet man let's get one
again oh [ __ ] it's okay
sorry we'll get that what's the paper
towel budget what you're saying i'll get
it
okay we'll figure it out spade hey
it's uh adam egatt from the office um
do you know where the paper clips are i
really need these
as soon as possible i guess it looks
[ __ ] over here
um also corn dogs for lunch today so
let me know if you want me to save you
one what kind of halfway through
uh theo i said hi uh yeah call me back
as soon as you get this i need to know
about these paper clips like
stat i will tell you adam who's still
using paper clips yeah i know he doesn't
know the fact that
there's actually two more jesus christ
from him yeah and this is he
when he write these you're [ __ ] solid
yeah
okay he doesn't do the monologue yeah
hey it's adam again
do you know how i changed my w-2 um
i think i'm 10 99 a.m amount of taxes
taken out
so i always say all right 300 uh call me
back
hey
are you hanging up hey uh it's adam
again
spade uh do you have a fire extinguisher
in your office um
he's no rush let's just uh
get back to no rush on the [ __ ]
message either jesus
what a slow poke rodriguez there's a
fire bro spit it
spade you know what happened
i yesterday he got a box of pens sent to
him
he's got a haul face he's got an office
let's say this is a big square room
right this big huge lot we are doing the
showing
over on the wall like that's his desk so
everyone walks this is a hall fest
because he just
everyone just walks through and does
their [ __ ] oh right he didn't get like
an office office at the door
so he sits there and everyone just makes
fun of him so
i he was someone put garbage on his desk
like these workers came put on his desk
while they were working and he just said
they're going the [ __ ] is happening
so on one of my stories i put on
instagram i go hey adam you get
hating is halfus and so this woman that
works for a pen
company sent him i mean maybe 300 pens
oh wow just they said hey i saw your
office looks needs a little
pen action on there so yesterday he was
like having a yard sale he laid them all
out and everyone got to come pick a pen
don't take the violent ones take green
he's like no no no green
and then everyone's like arguing about
which ones they want i mean like 300
yeah but they're like you any felt tip
he's like nah he's being snug with
someone like
adam you just got him free one minute
ago like no he loves being a uh
he loves the job though it seems like
he's he's been he loves he's good at it
yeah he's the guy that does the
comedians
and we have another department seems
like a total [ __ ] show but
we have a whole department that does
anyone's not a comedian
so like or you get too big like if leno
is a comedian but we have talent office
deal with them just because
you know there's some people that are
more i think jim carrey oh yeah we i
think jim carrey is coming on
really that's awesome love jim carrey
very soon
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch watches one